تهديد ووعيد وعقوبات اعدامه هي اللغه التي
تلوح بها السلطات الايرانيه التي حتى الان
تبدو مسره على قمع الاحتجاجات المتواصله
في البلاد وباي وسيله ممكنه رئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيس انضم ايضا الى قائمه طويله
من مسؤولين الذين يسرون على حسر تعاتم على
احتجاجات بالبعد الامنيه
رئيسيه
الشغب والمتسببين في مقتل افراد من قوات
الامن بعقاب شديد مستعينا ايضا بالقضاء
بعد ان اشار بشكل واضح الى محاكمات مشدده
بحق المحتاجين تصريحات تضرب عرض الحائط
الاصوات الدوليه التي تعالت مستنكره اول
حاله اعدام في ايران ذات صله بالاحتجاجات
فالامم المتحده استنكرت اعدام محسن شكاري
البالغ من العمر 23 عاما والمتهم بجرح احد
عناصر الامن ودعت الامم المتحده طهران الى
وقف فوري لعمليات الاعدام التي تعد مبعث
قلق بالغ وتهدف الى تخويف المحتاجين
واذا اقتصر رد الامم على التنديد فان
التطورات الدوليه قادت الى فرض عقوبات
جديده على طهران فبريطانيا رده بعقوبات
شميله 10 مسؤولين ايرانيين قالت انهم
مرتبطون بالنظام القضائي وقطاع السجونه
كندا بدورها صارت على المنوال نفسها وفرضت
عقوبات جديده شملته 22 فرضا من بينهم
اعضاء بارزون في القضاء والسجون الاتحاد
الاوروبي ايضا يتجه الى فرد عقوبات على
ايران نقلا عن الخارجيه الالمانيه عقوبات
تزيد من عزبه ايران التي تواصل ريهانا على
حل امنيين
دخلت شهرها الثالث العربيه